okay there you have it lib tardes Kuck
and snowflakes are the three words that
we want you to stop calling us in the
comments let us know which word you want
people to stop calling you see you next
time on every damn day Ryan that last
take was a take reminder the nurse will
be by this afternoon to give everyone
flu shots right and on health insurance
delicious let's cover rabies this dudes
dog lick me okay rabies from a dog
licking you I didn't tell you where you
licked me did it lick you on the voodoo
doll you keep on a chain around your
neck cuz that can give you rabies it
happened to my uncle he lives with the
wolves now okay guys let's just please
act normal today
[Music]
hi I um so you're like a doctor right no
I'm a nurse just here to give a flu shot
oh don't sell yourself short
listen getting this flu shot makes me so
nervous I feel like that maybe qualifies
me for some medical weed wink wink
I need five flu shots a shitload of zhi
packs and whatever medical exams i need
between the ages of 18 and 30 or you can
have one flu shot or no flu shots what
about three flu shots and I slip you a
20 okay this is sterile so it does where
I have to draw the line I don't trust
this so-called flu shot I'm sorry what
excellent yeah yeah they inject them all
with the legacy virus what do you think
Oh what I'm saying is this better not
put me in a place
Oh God so much anxiety I really could
use some medical MDMA or medical
whip-its there's no such thing as
medical with it whatever the medical
term is I just need to get as medicated
as possible
wink wink you know you're not even
winking when you do that thank you so
much for coming in yeah it's really
great because when you work full time
you know it's hard to find the time of
course yeah Oh actually could we do my
voodoo doll first you know so he doesn't
get jealous what is wrong with you
people
oh we make comedy content for the
internet so each of our brains is broken
in different ways okay great doll he
wants a shot put it down sure I'm gonna
get right in the middle of the neck
there great yeah yeah okay good well
he's good for the flu then okay
great job why do you have a special
trash can for evil use needles are a
biohazard
I get it you're trying to clone the
black man kill the originals and control
the clones who are you talking to Shh
I'm talking to my people so how's your
day going let me do my job okay
I am so so sorry I told them that normal
I appreciate your apology but please
never call me again
they're onto us Chris knows abort
operation chocolate clone drone
[Music]
you